Friday's White House briefing on the
cove at nineteen pandemic started like
any other opening remarks from President
Donald Trump today I signed the Paycheck
protection program and health care
Enhancement Act providing 320 billion
dollars to keep American workers on the
payroll Trump then stood aside to allow
updates from members of the pandemic
task force but after 21 minutes
he left the briefing room without
answering anyone's question Trump has
bragged on Twitter about creating
must-see TV by insulting journalists and
making Wilders pseudo medical claims but
the uproar after Thursday's briefing in
which the president suggested that
injecting disinfectant might cure people
with coronavirus may have been Trump's
cue to cut it short
right and then I see the disinfectant
where it knocks it out in a minute
one minute and is there way we can do
something like that by injection inside
or almost a cleaning because you see it
gets in the lungs and it does a
tremendous number long so it'd be
interesting to check that the president
tried to downplay his words earlier on
Friday now I was asking a question
sarcastically to reporters like you just
to see what would happen but the damage
had already been done
a major disinfectant company launched a
campaign warning people to ignore
Trump's advice and officials in New York
State and in Maryland say they're poison
control hotlines were flooded with calls
from people looking for a wonder drug
who didn't appear at Friday's briefing
dr. Anthony Falchi the government's
leading infectious disease expert and
dr. deborah birx whose reaction to
Trump's disinfectant comment was a
social media sensation the u.s. TV
networks have been accused of giving
Trump a platform to scare people and
spread dangerous information in exchange
for ratings but now there are reports
Trump may be cutting back on the daily
press briefings in part to boost his
standing with voters six months before
the election Rosalyn Jordan
- zero